on the occasion of universal children's  day children are questioning Parliament  president Antonio Tajani on children's  rights at an event organized with UNICEF  the Istanbul convention aims to  eradicate violence against women at a  national and EU level Parliament is to  discuss how the convention is ratified  and implemented the EU Parliament  scientific body is hosting its annual  lecture focusing on media and flows of  information in the age of artificial  intelligence the African continent is  set to become the youngest and most  populous continent in the world by 2050  African leaders will gather in Brussels  to discuss issues such as security  migration and human rights asylum seeker  applications in the EU actually  decreased compared to 2015 the director  of the European Asylum support office in  Malta is coming to Brussels to present  the 2016 annual report